15分ほど時間ありますけど
ご質問あればどうぞ  家族のことなんですが
人のことは放っておいて自分のことを［聞き取り不能］ということなんです
家内の車の運転がちょっと危険な状態もあるので注意するんですが
なるべく柔らかく注意するんですが
非常に怒ってしまうんです
で 子供たちともいろいろ相談するんですが
なかなかその辺をどうしたらいいかと思ったりんですが
それはあんたの仕事でしょうに
もうやってないでしょうに
だから女性がもうどうせもうそういう運転だからね
あんたの奥さんだけじゃないんですよ
乗ったもんじゃないんです
何でも人に責任転換するんですよ
女は だから まあだから男と女がいるんですよ
だからこの精神的に落ち着いているようにいろいろ話をしたりとかね
あれと面白いとかね しかし
あの あの建物ってかっこいいと言ってはいけないんですよ
あれ全部やめてそれ見るんだから
もうそれで死んでますよ
そうじゃなくて あの もういろいろ楽しい話とかね
観念的な話とかするしかないんです
あるいは所詮物事考えないんだから
もう褒めてあげればね
まあやっぱり女性に守られて楽しいとかね
どうせもう命を産んで育てる人々だから
もうお世話になりますよとかね
言うと もう一応胸を張って安全運転頑張るんです
まあ一番早い手段は褒めることなんですよ
批判は入りません ああいう脳細胞には
できてないんです 女性同士でもね
もうあれが悪い これが悪いとは言わないでしょうに
その代わり嫉妬する こらえて自分で苦しむ
男同士では言いたい放題ことを言って喧嘩もして
それでもすごい仲がいいでしょう
嫉妬しないでしょうに
だからこの友達っていうのはいかにすごいかっこよくて楽しいかっていうことは
あんまり女性たちはわからないんですけどね
女性たちはいっぱい仲間グループ作ってますけどね
男は一人 二人 三人とかね
そんなにたくさんいませんだけどね
だからそこはすごい思考が違うんですね
いつでもグループ作ってますけど
どこかでおかしいんですよ
一応 男のグループとは違うんです
まあとにかく早い方法はっていうのは褒めることですね
まあお世話になりますという感じでね
で お願いしますということで
全く本人に任せておいて
もうガチャガチャ言わないことも一つの方法で
自分と子供たちは別に気にしないで遊んでいると
そうすると自分がいきなり母親になっちゃって
まあこの連中わちゃわちゃ守らなくちゃっていうことになるんです
何も喋れない方がもしかするとママいくかもしれませんしね
まあ私ならまあ降ろしてくれと言います
どうぞ子供たち あなたの子供たちだから
私は別人と まあそれは言わんも極端なまま
当たり前 だからなんで奥様の方が運転するのかと
あんたいる場合はね それが問題でしょう
自分の仕事でしょう 大体運転っていうのは男の仕事で
まあ男は忙しくて もう場合はお母さんが車を運転して子供を学校から連れてくるとかね
それは買い物に行くとか
それはやってますけど
その時で私はいろいろ小説とかいろいろ読みますけど
英語でね ものすごい文法面白くて
なんか読みすぎになってますけど
最近の英語っていうのは絶対もう昔の小説と違うんですね
英語は そういうものすごい辛口言ってますよ
女性の運転の場合は なんか物騒みたいですね
それは 小説の中でも出てくるんだからね
で うちのお母さん運転する時はみんな車やめた方がいいよとかね
英語では それは他の人々は道路に車出したことが悪いんだと
なぜならば うちのお母さんが今運転しているんだよ
という風な この小説にも出てくるんだから
なんか合わないみたいね
パイロット見ないでしょ
外科とそういうもの 女にできません
荒っぽいんです 普通の医者はできるかもしれませんだけど
でもなんかどーも足らないんですよ
もう 医者の仕事の場合も
できないこといっぱいあります
料理できない 信じられないでしょうに
ではコックさんたちは誰ですかね
世の中に 外科の方がすごく下手
嫌になったら辞めるんだから
もうもう本当に止められないんですよ
もう 怒ったら即怒鳴るでしょうにね
相手は患者さんであると
それは普通のもう内科とかの場合は別に誰もそんなにあまり気にしませんだけど
その外科ということになってくると
もう嫌になった もうあんたの態度良くない
もうやめたって それはちょっと困りますよ
そういう向いてないものもあります
そこら辺は男はそこはやってあげないと
あれって私でも何でしょうかね
車バックすると後ろにぶつかるまでブレーキかけませんね
ぶつけたらはい OK と
OK じゃないんだけど
それで気にしないんですよ
男っていうのはちょこっとでもかすり傷でも車についちゃうと
もうえらい気にするんですね
もう自分の腕が下手っていうことにものすごいんですよ
もうあ ぶつけちゃったか
私の友達が今アメリカでもうかなり上の人ですけどね
あのキリスト教者のもうこっちで社長やってましたけど
すっごい車 車でしたからね
乗っていた車は これでなんだかんだ仕事だから
もう日本に2日いると
もう3日間他の国ということで
もうもう大体 2ヶ月とかで新しいパスポートに変えなくちゃいけないんだと
もう行ったり来たり忙しいんですね
だから子供がいて まあもう学校に連れて行ったりとかね
もう買い物したりとかいろいろしなくちゃいけない
だからもう平気でぶつかる
もういわばスリランカ人でしたからね
いくらかもうしっかりはしてるんですけども
女性の方はね 普段はすごい立派な方なんですよ
ものすごい話は上手ですし
物事をものすごいきっちり考えるし
でも何時間でもごちゃごちゃ喋ってますよ
面白いんですよ 子供だけ任せちゃって
どうするかわからない
それにもある日私が言ったら
もう私迎えに別な車で来たんですね
それあの車だと まあごっつい車だからね
あれ あれはまあ あの人もう名前なんとか忘れちゃった
あいつもうぶつけちゃったんだから
もうあれ 3ヶ月とかかかりますよ
全然それに文句も何も意味がないんですよ
それで友達みんな集めてニコニコと笑ってるんですよ
もう車すっごいぶつけちゃって
もう修理には 3ヶ月ぐらいかかると
で 奥さんも笑ってるんですよ
それに あ そうなんですよと
言って それは新しくもう変わってる車にしたって同じことやっちゃってますよ
そこまで男は心配しないんです
やっぱり あれに何かガチャガチャ悪口も言わない
それがもう まあ受け止めるのはそんなもんですよ
やっぱりそれはまあ女性だからね
そこら辺はまあできないところだと
でも現代社会でしょうがなく
もう運転しなくちゃいけないし
もうできないことだからね
それでぶつけちゃってね
俺も 40万ぐらいもうかかっちゃって
まあしょうがないと 払いますと
その人お金があったんだからいいんですけどね
まあそういうことで面白いんですよ
平気ですよ ぶつけても
他の車と衝突しちゃうと向こう側が悪くなっちゃいますから
だから向こうの運転手
男性だったら逃げた方がいいのに
いくらこちらが間違っていたってもうかかっていくんで
お前が悪いんだと スリランカで我々それ冗談で
もう車の中見るの あ あの車気をつけろと
信号が赤くなったって
自分で飛ばしたければ飛ばすと
だからそういう能力ないところは仕事を頼まないっていうのは正しいんですよ
しょうがないでしょうね
今更ね もう別に 女性には女性の思考パターンと生き方がありますからね
現代人があれこれやとね
機械作ったんだからといって
それに慣れるわけじゃないんですよ
おそらくね 子供育てるためにわざとこの遺伝的にそういうプログラムを外れている可能性もあります
みんな人間だから そこも慣れちゃえ
習っちゃえばいいでしょうにね
でもダメですよ 習いませんね
しかし 善悪やらね もうそういうことやら悪いことやら
これは見事にもう 5  6歳になってくる
全部学んでますよ 男はもう二十歳になってもできないのに
30歳になってもできないのに
小さい時からそれはしっかりついています
だから面白いところは
まあまあ そこはまあ生命だから
あまり理屈っぽくなっちゃうと子育てはできないんだからね
まあ取り消されています
その能力は いい加減で乱暴でないと子育てはできません
いっぱい屁理屈持ってないと子供は育ちません
それは必要なものですよ
だって子供の話聞いちゃうと
もう話にならんでしょうに
だから女性は初めから人の話を聞かないようにできているんです
それで子育てではうまくいくんですよ
子供の話は聞かない いくら子供は弁解しても
ちゃんと情報を提供して
これだからこれで え？ダメです
それは  [笑い]それはまあ子孫を育てるために必要な能力ですよ
だから能力ないと見るよりは
それは一つの能力として見た方がいい
車運転できない能力 [笑い]地図はわからない能力
[笑い]方向音痴という能力があるんだと
方向音痴ですね [笑い]それ一つの能力として見たら
だから地図は読めないは方向音痴でしょうに
だからもう例えば子供が抱えてると思っちゃうと
そちらにいるんですよ
あっちこっち行かないで
子供あちこち行かせません
方向あれこれ全部知ってると
子供があちこちうろうろ遊んだってのも気にしないんですよ
まあすぐ見つかるんだからと
知ってますよと ああ まあこれならね
今十五分経ってるんだから
あの子供なら今あっちいるでしょうと
それ危ないんですよ そちらでちょっと瞬間に何するかわからないんだから
子供だからね ちょっと足が滑っただけで死ぬかもしれませんでしょうに
だからそれは必要な能力なんですよ
能力ないではなくて 街とかあっちこっち連れていくでしょ
子供たちを どこにも行かせません
もう こっちになさいと
電車で見るんです 電車の中だからちょっと遊んでもいいでしょ
遊びません こちら座りなさい
[笑い]男の子だったらちょっとうるさかったりなんてダメ
あの 自分知ってる あの
何て言いますか 縄張りからは出さないんですね
その時私は自分でイメージで
あの あれでシミュレーションに考えるんですよ
やっぱりこの子供とこの子供
もし私が連れて行ったならば
思い存分遊ばせるのにとかね
あっち走ってみろと言うのにとかね
私だったら走らせるんです
あんなの走ってみろよと
空いてるんだから邪魔ないんだからと
それはやっぱり男の思考ですよ
で 電車で座席ずっと空いてたっても
お母さんだったらこちらに座れと
あっちへ行くなよと そういうことですから
そういうね あの女性にはそういう能力あるんですよ
一応 方向音痴という能力から運転できない能力から
まあそういうのは能力として見た方がいいんです
怒る必要はありません
怒る 怒ることできないんですよ
別に  よろしいでしょうか
では もう時間ですので
最後にサンガ依して終わりにさせていただきます
サンガ依 はい ではどうもありがとうございます